[Musique]
olivier parent et japon jour en jour
bienvenue à montigny le bretonneux
commune voisine de la vôtre puisque vous
êtes élu à aiguillon courante à sein du
conseil municipal est lui aussi à saint
quentin en yvelines
et puis vous êtes alors l'ancien
responsable départemental d'europe
écologie les verts s'est tout récemment
ses tours et c'est en fait ça fait
quatre ans maintenant que j'étais
responsable départemental d'europe
écologie les verts donc c'est pour moi
un peu le temps de passer à autre chose
de changer un petit peu de type
d'investissement le politique on va
s'attarder un petit peu sur ça ça veut
dire déjà que vous quittez europe
ecologie les verts ou pas du tout gg
aucun comment dire le programme d'europe
écologie les verts les convictions
écologistes s'agit absolument pas changé
la question que je me posais c'est une
interrogation aujourd'hui c'est la forme
parti politique c'est à dire que si on
prend par exemple les dernières
législatives
on se rend compte que malgré la
multiplicité des candidats sur les
circonscriptions ici on en avait entre
13 et 15
donc il y avait vraiment une offre
politique classique énorme et finalement
il ya la moitié des gens qui ne se sont
pas déplacés pour aller voter
donc ça interpelle sur le fait que
finalement cette forme-là a peut-être
ses limites je vois aussi quelque chose
qui m'a fait moi réfléchir sur les
dernières élections sénatoriales par
exemple où finalement on voit que la
logique des partis politiques qui arrive
pas à s'entendre
chacun pour exister font qu'on n'arrive
pas à avoir à un sénateur ou une
sénatrice de niaréla italien dans la de
gauche depuis alors que finalement
qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est que le parti
socialiste n'a pas réussi à s'entendre
avec les écologistes
présentée sandrine dans gangs qui
finalement quelques semaines après se
retrouvent dans le même groupe à la
région il ya des nouvelles d'appareils
il ya des logiques d'appareil qui moi me
semble aujourd'hui à la fois difficile à
suivre enfin pour moi personnellement
bien sûr et on voit bien qu'une grande
partie des gens ne se retrouvent pas là
dedans donc je pense que il faut il faut
essayer de trouver une autre forme
il ya des choses très intéressantes qui
se passe dans certaines villes avec
beaucoup plus de participation citoyenne
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé à l'époque
lorsque vous avez rallier europe
ecologie les verts c'était en 2009
voilà c'est ça 2009 2010 c'était
l'époque où où tous les écologistes
s'étaient rassemblés donc on retrouvait
aussi bien daniel cohn bendit josé bové
eva joly on trouvait des proches de
nicolas hulot comme pascal durand ou
jean paul besset donc il y avait
vraiment et en particulier au niveau des
européennes de 2009
un vrai
rassemblement de tout un tas de
personnalités pas toujours exactement
sur sur les mêmes positions mais qui
avait vraiment un corps d'une idée
commune autour de l'écologie et ce
mouvement là était très ouvert et
rassembler bien au-delà de la frontière
de ce qui était à l'époque les verts
donc moi je suis rentré dans cette
dynamique là qui existait au niveau donc
européen national régional puisque c'est
l'été d'époque vers 2010 je crois que
c'est il y avait les élections
régionales et même localement
les écologistes étaient vraiment ouvert
à de manière importante et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui avec toutes les
péripéties les bisbilles au niveau
national etc
on n'est plus tout à fait dans cette
dans cette dynamique là vous avez
mentionné le nom de nicolas hulot
nicolas hulot qui rejoint le
gouvernement qui obtient un ministère
c'est un bon signe même si on a vu il a
dû reculer un peu ça ça aurait une
position sans doute l'air notamment
alors initialement moi j'ai trouvé que
c'était un très bon signe c'est après
après six mois là et le nombre de
couleuvres qu'il a dû avaler enfin je
pense pas qu'il ait été convaincues
surtout les changements que ça soit le
changement de la place position de la
france sur le dif hosatte par exemple au
niveau européen c'est quand même un
pesticide qui empoisonnent les aliments
sur son recul sur différents sujets sur
le nucléaire sur des choses comme ça
j'ai du mal à comprendre
j'espérais que il est puisse lui par sa
personnalité son aura arriver à faire
bouger plus les lignes et on voit que
non on retombe dans les mêmes schémas
que précédemment les mêmes schémas que
que les septennats précédent finalement
nouveaux combats à vous on va en parler
à présent et notamment cette ligne 18 à
saint quentin en yvelines parce que vous
êtes l'un des rares élus si ce n'est le
seul à vous opposer à cette ligne 18 le
passage par saint quentin en yvelines
glynn 18 ans et ce super métro de paris
vers saclay pour faire simple et qui
passe par saint quentin il serait menacé
pour des raisons budgétaires notamment
les élus des différentes agglomérations
pas uniquement 50 ans aussi versailles
se mobilisent vous aussi vous êtes
mobilisés
mais pour que cette ligne ne se fasse
pas en fait le principal
sujet c'est quelle est surdimensionné
dire que qu'il faille un transport et
reste à définir sa forme est ce que ses
débuts sa haute qualité de service est
ce que c'est un tramway pour relier
saint quentin en yvelines au plateau de
saclay à massy et éventuellement à orly
nous on est bien sûr pour ce genre de
transport en commun et le fait qu' un
tcsp donc transport en site propre donc
des lignes dédiées pour le bus sur le
plateau sur le long de la départementale
36 c'est quelque chose pour lequel on
milite depuis des années donc l'idée
c'est papa de transport c'est simplement
camp nou mais une infrastructure qui va
coûter extrêmement cher et qui est
capacitaire pour trois cent mille
personnes ou quatre cent mille personnes
par jour alors que les prévisions disent
qu'il n'y en aura que 100 à 150 milles
on se demande quel est l'intérêt de
mettre une infrastructure aussi loin
d'anticiper aussi tout à fait mais
l'anticipation c'est quoi c'est nous ce
qui nous fait peur c'est que une fois
que cette infrastructure très lourdes se
remplace la région parisienne les villes
nouvelles quand elles ont été créées
dans les années 80 90 elle n'était pas
dans la continuité urbaine de paris et
l'histoire c'est que paris enfin la
métropole urbaine de paris
c'est en sept ans a rejoint toutes les
villes nouvelles autour de paris et
maintenant la question est est-ce qu'on
continue avec la même logique que dans
les années 70 80 ou un moment on dit ben
non il faut peut-être un autre
aménagement du territoire et laisser des
terres agricoles sur le plateau de
saclay on est obligé de faire venir des
camions on est obligé de faire venir de
l'alimentation de très loin alors qu'on
a des terres agricoles tout près donc
préservons les après il ya quelque chose
qui nous paraît aussi évident c'est que
la ligne 18 et la dernière du grand
paris express
donc c'est celle qui en nombre de
voyageurs transportés par rapport à son
cours et est la moins
la moins évidente mais ça avait été
signalé par de nombreux rapports et donc
à un moment c'est un peu évident que ça
va être le fusible est donc plutôt que
de continuer à se battre pour dire il
nous faut en 2030 voire 2024 mais la
personne n'y croit c'est vraiment donc
que en 2030 on et se met trop lourd
mettons au lieu de mettre 3 4 milliards
pour faire semer trop lourd mettons des
centaines de millions pour améliorer les
transports d'aujourd'hui qui serviront
aux gens tous les jours pour aller
éventuellement sur paris sur versailles
sur massy mais mais mettons de l'argent
qui servira de l'année prochaine ou dans
deux ans quand il ya plusieurs combats
dont on pourrait parler aussi parce
qu'on est juste à côté du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous étiez
opposé aussi récréation de ce vélodrome
tout à fait et le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est quelque chose qui est un vélodrome
nationale en france bah oui il faut
pourquoi pas c'est par un problème en
soi simplement pourquoi la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est le
principal financeur de ce vélodrome
pourquoi elle ça va nous coûter 3 au 4 à
5 milliards tous les ans un million tous
les enfants nourris avec le métro c'est
des milliards levés sur des millions
restants à des millions donc c'est va
nous coûter 4 ou 5 millions tous les ans
à nous saint quentinois pour avoir une
installation d'intérêt national c'était
à l'état ou à la fédération de cyclisme
de financer cet équipement la pratique
on voit les jeux olympiques y aura des
retombées aussi pour le territoire
alors les retombées sur le territoire on
voit les lois qui sont en train de
passer ou toutes les exonérations de tva
toutes les haies les la publicité qui va
être organisée par le comité olympique
n'est absolument pas locales les
retombées locales bien sûr il y aura un
peu sur les hôtels etc
mais l'agglomération n'est quand même
pas rempli les retombées locales vont
être assez minime sur l'agglomération là
là on parle quand même d'un d'une dette
qui va durer pendant presque 30 ans et
votre profession si je ne dis pas de
bêtises vous êtes ingénieur automobile
exactement automobile qui n'a pas
toujours bonne presse en ce moment pour
un écologiste en plus effectivement on a
chacun ses méthodes sa schizophrénie
d'enjeux en fait bon effectivement je
suis je travaille depuis des années
comme ingénieur est bon aujourd'hui on
va pas se passer des automobiles demain
donc j'ai encore quelques années de
travail voilà après oui automobiles
propres après quel est le modèle est ce
que c'est des voitures individuelles est
ce que c'est de l'autopartage est ce que
c'est du transport en commun ont parlé
de l'écologie il n'y a pas que
l'écologie dans votre combat
on peut aussi peut-être parler du
soutien à la palestine vous êtes assez
actif dans ce domaine tout à fait
j'étais encore il ya il ya quelques
semaines
donc c'est quelque chose que j'ai
découvert en y allant
bon je pense que beaucoup de gens en
france ont une sympathie pour le peuple
palestinien et en se disant bon après on
comprend pas trop ce qui se passe et
c'est je pense que c'est la majorité
déjà en france et moi j'ai eu
j'ai eu l'occasion d'y aller pour voir
pour voir ma famille qui travaille pour
la croix rouge sur place
et là je me suis rendu compte sur place
en voyant ce que subissaient les
palestiniens les palestiniennes tous les
jours le l'oppression militaire
elle est vraiment les restrictions de
droit mais complètement incroyable qu'on
peut voir sur place et de ce voyage qui
avec a eu lieu en 2010 je crois je suis
revenu convaincu qu'il fallait expliquer
que l'on pouvait pas laisser le statu
quo actuel qui en fait est un stade du
coup complètement déséquilibré c'est à
dire cesser une armée qui occupe un pays
qui est aux marges d'être connu
puisqu'il est déjà observateur à l'onu
donc c'est passé c'est pas c'est pas une
invention de toutes pièces donc un pays
qu'est aux marches d'être connu et qui
complètement occupé par un autre et
cette chose là n'est absolument pas
dénoncer ou pas au niveau où je pense
que la compréhension que moi j'ai vu en
ayant la chance d'aller sur place il n'y
a pas
papa tu pas grand monde ne l'a donc
c'est pour ça que aujourd'hui j'ai envie
que ça soit engagée dans ce dont on a
fait tout à fait pour terminer cet
entretien un questionnaire rapide
votre livre de chevet actuellement alors
il s'appelle c'est les utopies réaliste
donc qui aurait explique des choses
passionnantes comment par exemple nixon
a failli mettre en place le revenu de
base aux états unis c'est quand même
assez assez incroyable ou comment en
ouvrant les frontières on pourrait
générer de l'activité économique plutôt
que de les fermer de dépenser de
l'argent à empêcher des gens qui ne
peuvent pas vivre correctement dans leur
pays devenir de venir chez nous donc ce
ce livre là j'ai et l'autre livre que
j'ai en ce moment mais il même s'il est
sorti il ya quelques années c'est c'est
celui de martin debiesse la terre
précieuse qui est sur l'histoire des
agriculteurs du plateau de saclay
comment l'agriculture sur le sur le
plateau s'est transformée comment
comment se sont implantées des centres
de recherche comment les associations
comme été récités et ses sons sont venus
sur le sur le plateau de charles tex
voilà ces deux livres qui délivre de la
musique que vous écoutez en boucle
principalement du jazz donc avec des
gens qu'on a pu voir par exemple ici au
prisme comme avishai cohen
tout ça n'est pas très local aussi bien
dans la littérature que pour la musique
on voit le lien avec amiens entouré avec
le nom mais c'est juste pour souligner
la richesse qu'on a dit sur le
territoire de pouvoir aller sur le
théâtre national au prisme et c'est pour
voir les peintures d'envergure
internationale sur ce et le dernier film
que vous ayez vu alors le dernier film
que j'ai vu je vais beaucoup au théâtre
local de le dire le dernier film
ça devrait en tout cas si ça doit être
120 battement cet été ça doit être ça
doit dater d'un moment merci olivier par
hazard lille 1-0 écologistes qui reste
engagée même si vous reprenez un petit
peu de recul vous nous l'avez expliqué
avec la formation politique avec europe
écologie merci à vous merci
[Musique]